oh my gosh I'm still not over last
night's episode and insane Tribal
Council an insane Blind Side there seems
to be a lot of blind sides this season
not I don't see them coming you guys
don't see them coming obviously so how
are you feeling now that this episode is
out there and everyone kind of saw what
unfolded it's it's weird you know like I
really enjoyed watching it back just to
see what fully happened
um because like from my perspective I
didn't know who threw my name out there
to be honest I didn't know exactly how
many books I was going to be catching
that day I did know I was catching a few
to be clear it wasn't like a complete
Blind Side that was catching votes it
was the number
um going into tribal I thought was going
to be four or five ended up being seven
um so yeah it's it's crazy but it's it's
relieving to finally see everything oh
well that's a good attitude to have
that's so interesting to hear that you
did know that some Boats were going to
be thrown your way were there any people
um that voted for you that surprised you
that they voted for you the only
surprises were Jesse and Cody uh the
other five were kind of expected going
in so I know the question is like if
you're going to catch five why don't you
play the idol I tried to undo the split
vote right before tribal unfortunately
like I didn't have enough time to get
enough people to listen but I thought I
did and that's just another reason of
how everything went down that day
it seemed like on the beach after the
immunity challenge like again it was
another chaotic at least it appeared to
be another chaotic
um post immunity challenge scramble on
the beach everyone was kind of trying to
figure out what was going to happen what
was the energy like after the immunity
challenge
um it was a scramble just not nearly as
much compared to the Ellie vote like the
elevo was just yeah people were running
every minute like I did not sit down for
a conversation like to be out of
conversation but that one was a bit more
calm like the only real scramble
um
I mean they were scrambling all day but
we had time we had the beach uh to you
know clean off from the mud challenge
and that caused the perfect cover for
the knowledge's power Advantage because
while I wasn't you know in the water
cleaning off someone can go up to camp
and grab knowledge's power so we had
some time to relax but after like an
hour or so it was just constant game
talks again
yeah absolutely now
Janine gave you her Idol right
so and we saw at the very end when like
things were starting to come together
that you were the one going to be sent
home that she was reaching for the idol
I don't know if you can confirm or deny
did she get it back did you walk away
with it or are we gonna have to wait and
see Janine did not get the idol back
oh my gosh what a plot twist
s
it was yeah so uh to be clear when she
was like doing that she wasn't like
reaching for the idol she was just like
patting my leg to make sure I was okay
like it looked like she was like trying
to reach for it yeah and if he was like
because I was like telling you was like
like I talked to her during tribal like
because I was trying to undo the split
and I was like you need to vote for
James under the split she was like no no
we're fine like patting my leg of like
you're we're good like we can keep
things as they are
um so that's where that came from and
yeah she's trying to calm me down I
guess like she was a lot more confident
in the plan
um I thought I was just being paranoid
so I was like you know what maybe it's
fine uh maybe she's right but maybe
actually my paranoia win the day at that
point they actually just you know said
like the idol will be played
um but no she did not get the idle back
unfortunately oh my gosh so now that she
doesn't have her Idol and it clearly her
and Noel were both blindsided by your
departure they're kind of at the bottom
now so what do you see for them moving
forward how will they get further in the
game you know I'm just hoping that they
can like reintegrate themselves I think
Janine made a had a good statement after
deliber was like let me be an asset and
I think she's done really well trying to
like reintegrate after you know getting
blindsided unfortunately the merge has
not been kind to Janine so far she lost
uh her best friend in Ellie
um she lost a good Ally and friend in me
and she lost her Idol so it's like
surely things can go better from here uh
so really really hoping that she end the
welcome Bill to integrate themselves and
Noel integrated herself after the
Justine vote pretty well so you know
we've seen it happen from her before so
I have full face ability to do it again
absolutely now during tribal I just want
to go back when Jeff was asking everyone
how confident they were and how the vote
was going to go like I could kind of see
the wheels spinning in your head what
was going through your head when
everyone was reading out you know nine
nine eight and you said seven I think
and then you knew votes were coming to
you like walk me through that yeah so I
knew that Coco was voting for me I knew
Samuel voting for me so I was five
um so for me like as people were saying
in numbers I was like okay it's kind of
lining up to people who are against me
or super confident people that should be
on my side are also cop like you can't
read too much into that because like
Ryan said seven as well but I was trying
to get votes off of Ryan near the end
like a lot for a lot of reasons one I
just want to undo the split to Ryan and
I had a pretty good moment out there
that like as a as like as a person he
was he was there for me that day we just
yeah just it was it was a lot going on
um but yeah it was
it definitely I was like oh maybe I am
in trouble maybe these people are
confident for a different reason nah
it'll be fine last time we did this I
last time they said numbers I survived
this time I did not
and there we go
um now looking back and seeing
everything kind of unfold on television
we obviously don't see everything that's
going on at camp but who would you say
is running the game right now
running the game right now
that's tough
um you could take your pick between
for after this vote and like the last
one I'd say James Jesse Cody
what like those those are the big three
I'd say like they like knew about the
past two votes they got votes the way he
wanted to they did a good job
campaigning and you know they got the
two of us out pretty well I mean pretty
effectively so let's say the kind of
Crux of power lies with those three and
Carla as well uh she was in on it she
was on she was on this on this book more
but yeah I feel like Carla's kind of
like not being seen as like kind of a
not a puppet master but she's really
like involved but no one really knows
and yeah that's very accurate because
like when I went home I genuinely was
like okay yes he's just he's existing
right now I didn't realize how much
power that she had in in reality yeah
um and then just taking it back to the
immunity challenge
um when it cut this is the first time at
least that I can remember in a long time
where they've really switched things up
you guys had to do the challenge in
pairs how does like strategy change
obviously you guys picked rocks and you
didn't pick your partners but how does
strategy change when you are relying on
your team mate to like help get you
through those obstacles
um Emilia you're looking at like first
of all you look at how you win so when
he walked to his challenge he was like
okay the winner is gonna be based on
like the bucket holding thing and look
at my partner my partner is Cody
do I think I'm like someone athletic
maybe but also I know my strengths I am
in no Universe beating Cody in a bucket
challenge so part of me was like do I
just throw the damn thing because I
don't want you know if if I go to the
end I'm just guaranteeing I never went
immunity and he would get over me but at
the end of the day I was like I gotta
you know I gotta bet on myself and it's
still gonna play 100 and you know we
work them all together in a challenge to
be fair like we killed it on The Ropers
thing the net we were behind was like we
worked well together in challenges even
though back on Bessie we worked well
together
um so although it was like kind of for
me I was like maybe I can't win this one
I still just wanted to compete in that
regard I think that was the same for
everybody uh everyone gave it 100 you
saw noelle's leg came off during the
challenge involuntarily and she still
was like going through that net and she
tried her best it didn't work out but
like she is such a badass competitor
like everybody was giving it their best
for their partner that they met maybe
two or three days ago so that was it was
great absolutely and just to wrap things
up I know you said you were disappointed
that you were like one vote away for
making the jury but so with all that
said and done and where you are now how
do you feel about your Survivor Journey
was it everything that you expected and
hoped it would be absolutely yeah I
loved every minute of it even though
like of course I wish it was a bit
longer I wish I made the Jerry and all
these things like I wouldn't trade for
anything in the world like that's I want
to do this for a while you see the flag
you see I have the shirt and everything
like this is something I wanted to do
since I was a kid and I got to do it and
I'm super happy with how I played and
how everything went amazing well it was
lovely chatting with you and seeing your
game play out even though the way it
ended it was still very entertaining and
it was awesome to watch you on on screen
so I appreciate that yeah thank you so
much for your time thank you for the
rest of the season as well thank you so
much hope you enjoy it too oh I will
yeah Survivor stand over here I'm ready